Hello, and welcome back.
Our goal for this class is to develop a parallax effect using the Bump Offset node on a surface
that looks translucent, but it isn't.
Let's get right into it.
So since our exercise will be quite extensive today, we'll be jumping directly into the
engine and cut the slides a little short, but remember that each step that I will
be taking in Unreal will also be displayed through screenshots and instructions here
in the slides so you can easily follow along.
Together with the sample material we will check out in just a moment, you should be
able to walk in the right direction as we draft a new material out.
Our goal for today is to create a Bump Offset material, and we'll be introducing two new
nodes, the Noise node and the Bump Offset node.
Alright, let's jump straight into the engine and see them in action.
Okay, we're in the Bump Offset section of our default map, and down here we can see
displayed two examples of materials using the Bump Offset node.
Here on the left we see how the Bump Offset was used in conjunction with the normal map,
and if we get close to these pebbles we can see how they really look elevated from
the surface.
So the Bump Offset node together with the normal map are really creating a nice three-dimensional
effect.
Let's turn here to the right to analyze this gemstone material now, where the Bump Offset
node was used to create a nice parallax and depth effect.
It looks as if we could almost enter this material, and it's really cool.
Now, when creating materials with the Bump Offset node, we need to make sure that the UVs on
our object are well mapped, and that the texture is correctly tiling, because if I
start zooming into this rock down here, I don't know if you noticed this before, but
if I start panning a little bit to the right, we can see that as we get closer to this
border here, the illusion of parallax start really breaking down, because the UV mapping
on this object wasn't correctly set up.
Now if we were always looking at this rock from this point of view, it would be alright,
and nobody would be noticing anything weird with it.
So this is just something to be aware of if your player or your camera needs to get
close to these kinds of materials.
Alright, let's start with reviewing the pebbles material first, then we'll be taking a look
at the gemstone material, and after that we will be creating the gemstone material
from scratch.
Let's select the preview mesh for the pebble material, and down here in the details
panel, we can open up its material assigned to it.
Alright, the first thing I'm going to be doing here is switching the preview mesh
from the sphere to the cube, because I think that a flat surface is going to help
us understand better what's going on, and then I'm going to zoom into it.
Okay, so let's review what's going on here.
We have a bump offset node, where the height input is connected to the red channel
of this texture sample.
Let's connect the red channel of this texture sample directly into the base color
to see how it looks like.
Okay, so we can see that this texture sample is really providing us with the height information
that we need, but most of the heavy lifting in this material is actually given by the
normal map.
So let's just try by pressing Alt on our keyboard and then clicking on the input
pin of the normal to unplug the normal map, and here you can see how essential
it was in the development of our material.
This material is still a little bit interesting because its specularity and roughness are
still connected to it, so it does have some nice details.
But its elevation and three-dimensionality is completely gone.
So let's connect the normal map back again, and I'm also going to be connecting
the base color to what we had before.
All right, so you can see here that this bump offset node is also connected to the
texture sample of the base color.
I'm going to be showing you why.
So let's just zoom into the texture down here, and I want to find a position of the
camera where we can easily see some nice ambient occlusion, like here or here.
Now I'm going to be unplugging the bump offset from the base color, and you can see
that a little bit of the ambient occlusion detail is now gone.
So that's actually what this is doing.
It's just adding some nice ambient occlusion around the pebbles, which is actually improving
this feeling and illusion of depth.
Okay, so then we have some few nodes up here that you can play around with.
You can also just totally change all the textures you want, changing the colors.
Nothing is set to stone here, or maybe I should say set to pebble.
All right, so then up here we have a series of nodes that we use just to add some imperfections
or just some texture variation, and that is really it for this graph.
So we can just close it down and go back to our viewport.
All right, now let's open up the gemstone material and see how this was developed.
So I'm going to be clicking on the preview mesh, and then in the details panel, I will
open up the material.
All right, so the first thing I'm going to do is again switching back the preview mode
from sphere to cube.
Okay, and now we're going to be recreating this material from scratch, so I won't be
diving too much into how this was made, but one thing that I want to mention is that
this material is not translucent.
It's actually opaque, even though it does give a translucent illusion, and you can see
here that we have something connected to the refraction index, even though the refraction
index is completely disabled.
So these series of nodes are not actually being calculated.
They're not actually being applied to the refraction index.
They are being applied to the emissive color that they're connected to, but the
refraction index is completely grayed out.
In order for us to be able to use the refraction index, we would need to be switching the
blend mode from opaque to translucent, and here you would see that the refraction index
would be enabled again, even though now a material looks a bit more ghost-like and
weird and not like a gemstone material anymore, but you can still use this for something
else, something a bit more mysterious maybe.
And remember that if you want to have access to the specular, roughness, and metallic
values of any translucent material, you need to make sure that the lighting mode is switched
to surface forward shading or surface translucency volume.
Okay, I think we can start out with building our new material, so I'm gonna be keeping
this open because we will be borrowing some nodes from this material.
Okay, so in the content browser, I will be creating a new material, and then I'm
gonna be calling it m underscore bump offset, but you can really call it whatever you
want, and then I'm gonna double click on it to open it up.
Okay, so first of all, let's go back to our gemstone material, and let's copy a few
textures that we can borrow from it, just to speed up our process.
We're gonna be taking the base color, and we're gonna copy also this whole
layout of nodes for the normal.
Then we want to be taking this soft smoke kind of texture, and this yellow one down
here, so we need these four main textures together with the normal setup.
Then I'm gonna Ctrl C to copy, and then Ctrl V down here, and we'll just
quickly move them in the right position.
Okay, so what we have here is actually a group of nodes that is typically used
to give granular and runtime control over normals.
In fact, this flattened normal, we can input the normals, and then we can define its strengths.
We're gonna wait a little bit before plugging in the base color and the normal,
because we will be connecting the outputs of nodes we'll be developing
directly to the base color to see some nice previews of what they're doing,
and I think it's gonna help us understanding what's going on.
Okay, let's start by creating a bump offset node by pressing B on the keyboard and
clicking on an empty area of the graph.
Okay, then we want to add a texture coordinate node,
and we want to connect it to a Multiply node,
and then we want to add a scalar parameter that we're gonna be calling
Interior Tiling, and let's set the tiling to 1.
Okay, and then the output of this Multiply node, we can connect it to the coordinates.
Now the preview of our bump offset is still black because nothing is connected to our height,
so let's take care of it by right-clicking on the height,
and then promote that to parameter, and here you can see that we start having some previews.
Let's set the height to 0.7.
Okay, then let's promote to parameter the height ratio,
and we can actually call it Interior Offset, and let's set this to 1.
Now let's plug this bump offset output pin directly into the base color,
and we won't be seeing much.
Actually, we'll be switching the preview mesh from sphere to cube.
We won't be seeing much going on, but this is just for you to know
that what the bump offset node is doing right now with our texture coordinates
is distorting them based on our viewing angle to create a fake depth effect,
and it's not very visible right now,
but as we continue developing the node, it will be more and more prominent.
Okay, so now what we want to do is connecting this bump offset node
to the UVs input of this yellow texture sample,
and we chose this particular texture sample
because it has a really nice and funky color information and contrast.
So let's open it up to see what I mean.
Now the red channel is basically empty.
If I isolate the red channel, you can see that it almost has nothing stored in it,
but if we enable the green channel or the blue channel,
especially, you can see how much contrast there is in it.
Today we'll be actually using a combination of the green and the blue channels,
which creates this really nice and weird texture.
Okay, let's go back to our bump offset,
and by the way, the more contrast our texture will have,
the clearer will be the high definition of our material.
Okay, so I'm just gonna move this texture a little bit to the side,
and now we will be introducing a new node.
So if I right-click in an empty area of the graph,
I can add the first noise node, and we haven't seen this node before.
So I'm just gonna open up our preview here,
and then let's just go in and change these values a little bit.
So let's set the scale to 0.01, the levels to 5,
the output min to 0, output max to 0.25,
and the level scale is fine at 2.
And we can start seeing here in our preview
that the texture we had before
changed to something a little bit more dissolved.
So the noise node actually generates random-looking patterns
that we can control based on these values.
This is basically like a random texture generator
straight into the engine.
One cool thing to notice is that since the noise nodes
are mathematically generated rather than from image files,
if we pan around the graph, you can actually see them self-dialing,
and I love this effect, it's really cool.
Okay, let's move on.
I'm gonna Ctrl-C on the noise, and then Ctrl-V to duplicate it,
and then I'm just gonna change the values
on this second noise node.
All right, we want the scale to be 0.1,
the levels to be 6, output min 0, output max 0.25,
and level scale 2.
So basically this noise node is a little bit chunkier
than our first one.
Let's now add a lerp node by pressing L on the keyboard
and left-clicking on the graph,
and we want to connect the first noise to the A,
the second noise to the B,
and the G channel of this yellow texture sample to the alpha.
And then let's plug the output pin to the base color
to see what's happening here.
So it's not very visible,
but the bump offset node connected to our texture sample
and then to the alpha of the lerp
means that we're basically blending
between these two noise patterns based on our camera angle,
and we're basically creating the illusion of depth
as we move the camera around.
We're basically creating a view-dependent texture effect
that simulates a simple parallax.
Now let's increase this effect a little bit more
to make it more visible by adding a multiply node,
and then let's multiply the output of the lerp
with the B channel of the texture sample.
And now if you plug this to the base color
and then we move the camera around,
we can really start seeing some parallax,
and it looks incredibly cool.
Okay, now ultimately this series of nodes
will be plugged into the emissive property
of our MIMI tool,
so I'm just going to be unplugging the base color pin
by pressing Alt on the keyboard
and then clicking on base color.
Let's connect our original base color texture
into the base color,
and then the normal into the normal.
Okay, now we can start adding a bit more variation
to our emissive texture over here,
and let's start multiplying this texture sample down here
with just a simple constant tree vector
that is going to really give the base color of our emission.
So you can choose any color you like,
and it's going to show really permanently in your material.
So I'm just going to make it maybe pink.
Okay, and I'll multiply it with the texture sample.
Okay, let's now multiply the result of this base color
and texture sample that I'm going to plug to the A,
not to the B,
with the output multiply node connected to the B.
Okay, one last step is missing,
and let's just give us a bit more control
on the intensity of the emission of our material.
So I'm just going to add one more multiply node,
connect the output pin of this multiply to the A,
and then I'm going to hit S on the keyboard
to add a scalar parameter
that I'm going to call emissive strength.
And I'm going to put a real high value
because I want to make this real visible,
and then I'm going to connect it to the D.
Okay, so now if we plug the multiply node into the emissive,
boom, you can see our final magical and parallax material.
Now, if I zoom in a lot into this material,
you start seeing this spherical artifact happening,
and this is really dictated by two main values,
the interior tiling and the height.
So if I switch the height to something like 0.4,
you can see that that's not happening anymore,
but we start seeing these weird artifacts on the edges.
So you really need to tweak these values
a little bit around
until you find the right balance of what you want.
All right, I hope you enjoyed this class,
and in the next video,
we'll be looking into advanced glass node effects
and techniques.
I'll see you there.
Bye.